check out this tweet we got this tweet
from Benny Johnson he posted the video
from Project Veritas I suppose I could
have just pulled it up from Veritas but
Manny Johnson had a really great hashtag
attached to it lied suddenly and we all
thought that was pretty good so shout
out to Benny and uh this is the video
I'll play just a little bit 10 minutes
long I'm not gonna play the whole thing
for you but we'll play a little bit of
this so you can see what happens
my question for you is why is Pfizer
want to hide from the public the fact
that they're mutating the covet viruses
I'm literally a liar I was trying to
impress a person on a date
don't touch me well this is not why the
way don't tell anybody who's just
working at a company
you really did please
can you please unlock your door no no
don't let them leave please unlock don't
let them leave please please unlock the
door then look at he attacks James look
at this
he says you can't just record people
like that actually you can
get ready
this is the best video in ages yo this
video is crazy that was the highlight
reel and we talked about it a little bit
yesterday so for those who don't know
the context James O'Keefe's project
Veritas was undercover filming a guy
who's listed as the direct a Pfizer
director of strategic research or
something like that and he's saying that
they're exploring mutating covid to sort
of preempt it so they can make more
vaccines make more money at the vaccines
he says don't tell anybody they even
have a clip in this where he's like
you're not recording me are you why you
keep talking about this you shouldn't
you don't don't be recording me or
whatever
so that's the context here now I think
James has been particularly forthcoming
in breaking down what this story is
you'll notice the first thing that James
shows in it is the guy saying I am a
liar I was trying to impress someone on
a date not true he says I'm not I'm not
a doctor he says I'm just a consultant
Veritas put that right in the first 15
seconds they want you to understand that
of course what you're going to hear from
the fact Checkers and I'll pull this up
is they're trying to make it seem like
Veritas came out and asserted that
Pfizer was doing this right no no what
Veritas came out and said was hey we got
this guy on camera who is listed as a
director at Pfizer saying they're
they're looking into doing this can we
get some answers as to what why he's
talking about that hey maybe maybe he is
just trying to impress some guy in a
date I would be surprised I talked about
it the other day I think that happens
people are you know there's hey let me
tell you about the corporate male
Seasons I'm involved in yeah for some
reason they think it'll attract a mate
the Third first that's why it's The
Thirst but yo um man like we got a bunch
of crazy news but when I actually saw
the video of the dude physically
attacking the Veritas crew and then take
a look at this at the end James leaves
let me play the like the last minute
check this out come on guys where's the
where's the car where's the vehicle keep
walking come on let me let me say so
he's leaving but let me I also I also
want to point out they locked the
Veritas crew in the restaurant this is
the weird thing James walks in all
calmly walks up to this this guy and
he's like can you can you answer why you
said these things the dude goes to the
the store owner store owner takes his
side immediately and James is like this
calm dude wearing a suit day like I'm
just a journalist asking questions
here's what gets crazy she says you need
to leave and he goes okay we're leaving
then this guy uh Walker says no no don't
let them leave don't leave and James is
like ma'am he doesn't want us to leave
should should we is it okay if we stay
and ask him a few questions then the
lady apparently or someone at the
restaurant goes and locks them in
event and James is like can you please
unlock the door and let me leave it's
the craziest story and then so here's
where we're at now James is leaving
check this out witness one of the most
remarkable interactions ever do we have
the iPad so we're getting into the
vehicle now where's our car
so it says Walker desperately tried to
stop a car he believed was crude by
Veritas
and that car is like what is going on
but but this by this point Jameson
production had already left the
restaurant
[Music]
he's charging the guy charging charging
charging I can't make a list at this
point
okay
who's here you'd arrest that guy
oh then if James O'Keefe was still there
they would have arrested Walker
here's what I got to say about this what
we should we should talk about
the ending there I think is the most
revealing that he tried to stop a random
car jumping up and down in the street
yeah what must be going through this
guy's mind that he would have such
what's unhinged reaction like Yo dude
lost it I'm kind of wondering you know
he works he's saying like I'm lying I
swear I'm lying and I'm wondering if he
spilled the beans in a situation where
uh
you spilled the beans like this you
could sink a multi-billion dollar
company you're going to cause a lot of
problems his reaction is only making it
worse yeah absolutely and like what's in
his contract that they can bring against
him now like what penalties oh bro the
advisor I can't imagine NDA violation
easy yeah at least I imagine that that
you know being in that situation could
end his career I mean who's going to
want to hire the guy well I mean to be
honest
If he if his reaction to James O'Keefe
was like look man they're really doing
it and I don't know what I'm supposed to
do and it freaks me out that's why I was
talking about it I got a job with James
okay
he could have been one of those
whistleblowers against one of those
gofundme's instead he loses his mind
attacks them now nobody no no not nobody
was anywhere but I don't know what do
you think is this just a guy who was
lying because he wanted some dude to
like him I think the big thing is we
just need the government and Pfizer to
just be honest with us I mean I feel
like this whole I feel like this whole
interaction was kind of like a microcosm
of covid since 2020 like if somebody
said something and then someone else
James O'Keefe came and said hey can I
get some more information on that and
then the regime and they lock him in and
they freak out you can't ask that
question you're you're the liar the
gaslighting starts you're the one that's
in the wrong then we all get locked
inside together I mean this has been the
reaction since kovitz started anytime a
reasonable person says hey can we get a
little bit more information on this this
is this is interesting that there was
the Wuhan Institute of Neurology right
there do you think maybe it came from
that lab boom you're new automatically
you say hey I don't want to you know
have to take this vaccine I don't want
to have to lock my community down and
then boom they are all over you just
like this the exact same reaction that
gentleman had stuff with wuhen I that's
the this the thing that really bothers
me the most is that is the most
obvious assumption that people are going
to make now I don't know if it's true or
not right whether it came from the the
lab or not personally it seems likely to
me but at the same time it also seems
the most obvious thing that people are
going to assume right you know so to to
New People's you know Twitter pages or
or social media accounts or whatever
for saying something that is
for an uninformed person the person
that's ignorant about
how viruses work and stuff making that
kind of conclusion saying oh well that
that seems it to me and then just being
like well you lose all of your your
social social media privileges just
because you thought of something that
seemed like an obvious idea the lab Lake
Theory stuff was weird early on during
the pandemic we we talked about it I
talked about it there was no issue on
YouTube then all of a sudden for like a
few months there was if you claimed it
was a lab leak all of a sudden it was
like now you're getting banned yeah then
all of a sudden it was gone again and
then Jon Stewart came out and he said
come on guys like you think the BET
coronavirus emerged from a wet market
across the street from the Wuhan
coronavirus Research Center yeah come on
and then Colbert actually argued with
him and I'm like at that point
everyone's kind of leaning the direction
and I think it's fair to say
it's there's there's no Direct
proof I I think it's fair to say common
sense or a reasonable assumption is yo
come on yeah but do we have like I'll
put it this way what we do have is early
on the pandemic there were researchers
at the University of Beijing who put out
a report or some research paper saying
that people have been bitten by bats and
peed on by bats
we I would like some sworn testimony on
that but hey look you're dealing with
communist China good luck getting it
right so I think it is a reasonable
assumption that it's the case but uh you
know what
I I don't know I'm not an expert I defer
to uh directors at Pfizer right let's
see what they have to say we'll work on
these things and tell their dates that
it most likely came from a lab because
they were doing gain of function
research yeah I
think he goes like all men I lied
the bigger the story the bigger the LIE
yeah for him to come out I lied I lied
it's like okay now I don't think you did
right you know if if he came out like
there's so many things he could have
done
he could have come out and been and
started just he could have told James
I've been working with the CEO directly
and then she started hammering out the
lies had totally discredited himself
instead he goes the route of physically
attacking screaming jumping in front of
cars yelling I'm a liar I'm a liar
please believe me it's like really bad
bro if you're a liar I'm not going to
believe you yeah you know what I mean
I'm gonna so I'll tell you what I think
I don't think he was lying to impress a
date I think he was trying to impress a
date
there's there's a part of this video I
think it's this video where right here
check this out check this out look at
this this part right here let me play
this part not want the public to know
that you guys are doing directed
evolution
oh yeah
I know it's freaking me out give me
these like flashbacks to that like same
organization of like those conservative
people who like randomly go into
organizations and then like the friend
people who are working these
organizations and they'll report them
which happened to people at Pfizer so
it's like freaks me out when people
start asking a lot of questions
because um I just want to know the
answer
oh my God
and he was oh man yep that's so crazy
what's going on here oh
That's crazy dude that's hilarious so
what this reminds me of why are we back
up here yeah because I want to know the
answer like Chris Hanson yeah so he
thought it but then he still wanted to
continue impressing his day and so the
next day when James O'Keefe comes in
he's just like oh man yeah we talked
about this before you were saying like
at what point do they start being
suspicious right that like if you keep
asking specifically about this job that
you're not supposed to talk about at
what point are they like maybe this
something's going on but I guess this is
this this person is so I don't know
unhinged maybe a little bit emotionally
his wife is why I think he's telling the
truth he actually gets to the point
where he expresses why are you asking me
this it kind of makes me feel like I'm
being recorded
yeah like he's starting to realize hey
wait a minute what I'm saying could be a
problem I think people stayed in though
third date I think he said third day
through the video man I mean I gotta say
I I do feel bad
because
these people are on dates
They're laughing they're enjoying
themselves this guy goes on some dating
app meets some guy he really likes and
then you know he's like I drive for
pizza they got this nice Pizza there
could you imagine like sitting down
you're chilling not trying to think
about work the dude you're actually with
is about to destroy your life yeah and
are you secretly recording you I do feel
bad for him it is also at the same time
hilarious I can't help it well no his
reaction going crazy is is hilarious but
I'm just like
man I think his brain broke when he
realized yeah he's totally panicking
yeah look when you get a Twitter
employee being like yeah we banned
people then the information gets
released by Veritas it's like well
what's the worst that's going to happen
your liberal friends are gonna be like
good for you screw those Nazis but what
happens if you come out and you're like
all those evil things have been accused
of that you don't believe are happening
I admit it to people in private and now
everybody knows I said it and that I you
know either I'm lying or we're doing it
so now now what are you gonna do yeah he
knows he's basically going to validate
the argument of the the other side that
they've already said is completely and
totally evil so where does that leave
him I think that's probably why he's
inside I bet the media comes out now and
says
unmentally unhinged man confronted by
veritas
story completely discredited you think
they're gonna throw him under the bus oh
yeah
saying because the it's true if he has
like they're going to use it for their
protection thanks for watching this clip
from the timcast IRL podcast hang out
with us live Monday through Friday at
8pm and become a member over at
timcast.com for uncensored members only
shows exclusive thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time